[MUSIC PLAYING]
CATHERINE D'IGNAZIO:
It's the human behavior
that is making the
brain of the machine.
That is how you make
the machine intelligent.
SARAH HANSEN: Today
on Chalk Radio,
how the future of artificial
intelligence and machine
learning education might
look a lot more human.
JACOB ANDREAS:
What's the difference
between saying, you know, a
restaurant review expresses
positive sentiment,
which is a very
complicated social phenomenon,
and saying that, you know,
a picture of the number 9 is
a picture of the number 9,
which is much less complicated
as a social phenomenon.
SARAH HANSEN: I'm your
host, Sarah Hansen.
This week, we're
talking with three
interdisciplinary collaborators
about their mission
to foster a new kind of approach
to computing technologies.
They've created
an assignment that
challenges students to take a
critical approach as they build
the technologies of the future.
CATHERINE D'IGNAZIO: I
am Catherine D'Ignazio.
I'm an Assistant Professor of
Urban Science and Planning.
JACOB ANDREAS: My
name is Jacob Andreas.
I'm an Assistant Professor
in the Department
of Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science
and also the Computer Science
and Artificial Intelligence
Laboratory.
HARINI SURESH: My
name is Harini Suresh.
I'm a fifth year PhD
student in Computer Science.
SARAH HANSEN: In spring 2021,
Catherine, Jacob, and Harini
were brought together as
part of a special initiative
called SERC from the MIT
Stephen A. Schwarzman
College of Computing.
SERC stands for the
Social and Ethical
Responsibilities of Computing.
CATHERINE D'IGNAZIO:
So the mission broadly
is thinking about how do we
cultivate responsible creators
of computational
tools and technologies
for the folks who
are going to go out
and be building the
tools of the future.
You know, in a lot
of cases, you don't
know what the ethical
implications of something
are until, you
know, a kind of more
abstract tool or
technology or algorithm
is kind of plugged
into the human context,
right-- like that
place where, you know,
the machine learning
and people meet.
JACOB ANDREAS: There have been
lots of high profile incidents
involving things like face
recognition software, people
trying to deploy
machine learning
systems in the context of things
like sentencing or recidivism
prediction, and in many cases,
having sort of seriously
harmful effects.
SARAH HANSEN: For
Jacob, exploring
the social
consequences of AI got
him to start thinking a little
differently in his own survey
course--
6.864 Natural Language
Processing, or NLP for short.
JACOB ANDREAS: The way
we have traditionally
taught machine learning classes,
it's always, OK, you know,
here's a data set of
photographs of digits.
Classify this picture as whether
it contains a 0 or a 1 or a 2
or a 3.
And you know, here's a data
set of restaurant reviews.
And they just happen to already
have assigned to them labels
for whether this is
a positive restaurant
review or a negative
restaurant review.
You know, go train the
machine learning model.
And at no point do
you stop and ask, OK,
but where did these
restaurant reviews come from?
And what's the difference
between saying a restaurant
review expresses
positive sentiment, which
is a very complicated
social phenomenon,
and saying that, you know,
a picture of the number 9
is a picture of the number 9,
which is much less complicated
as a social phenomenon.
SARAH HANSEN: So he teamed
up with Catherine and Harini
to show students
that the machine
part of machine learning is
very much influenced by humans.
HARINI SURESH: So the way
that machine learning systems
work in many cases is something
called supervised learning,
where the data set
contains examples as well
as labels for those examples.
So for example, in content
moderation, you might have--
in your data set--
comments from a message
board as well as
annotations that say this
is a toxic comment or this
is not a toxic comment.
So then what the machine
learning system is trying to do
is learn from that data What.
Makes up a toxic comment,
what are characteristics
of toxicity, and it uses the
annotations to figure that out.
And those annotations
typically come from somewhere.
So they might be
automatically generated
by looking at historically
what sorts of comments
have been moderated.
Or they might be
generated by people.
You might crowdsource this or
get specific groups of people
to annotate comments as
to whether they think
they're toxic or non-toxic.
And those would
become the labels
in the data set that
the machine learning
system would learn from.
CATHERINE D'IGNAZIO: We
need to train it basically.
And the way to train
it is you look either,
like Harini said,
at historical data
or you make your
own data set where
you and your team or you
and a group of people or you
hire people to say, this is
toxic, this is not toxic.
Or let's keep this one,
let's not keep that one.
And that-- that annotation--
that is how you make
the machine intelligent.
And so if we back
up a little bit,
it's the human
behavior that is making
the brain of the machine.
That's why, you know, that step
is really important in there,
that human step.
It's also the step that we
were trying to tune people
into as not just being just
like this objective thing
that the machine makes up by
itself based on completely
objective parameters
or whatever.
JACOB ANDREAS: People
take these classes
and then they go out
in the real world
and find themselves
building detectors
for even more
complicated things,
like these toxicity detectors.
And that was what really
felt like the sort
gap between the way we
were training people
and the way these tools were
getting deployed in practice.
SARAH HANSEN:
Together, they designed
a brand new assignment for
the course, one they hoped
would get students thinking
about the human element
of machine learning.
First, students
wrote instructions
for annotating data
sets, and then they
tried to follow each
other's instructions.
HARINI SURESH: The overall
goal of the assignment
was to try and
get students to go
from thinking about data as this
pre-existing, objective, ground
truth to thinking
about it as the product
of a long and complex process
that involves many steps
and is driven by human
judgments and values.
The goal of this
assignment is not
to say that data is
not useful or that it's
bad but rather to help students
critically think about data
sets when they receive them
or use them or hear about them
being used and to help them sort
of ask those questions of who
was this created by,
how was it created,
what are its capabilities,
and what are its limitations.
SARAH HANSEN: When Catherine,
Harini, and Jacob started
reading the students'
responses, they
realized that the
assignment helped
students think differently
about the instructions they
were giving annotators.
But it also did something
none of them had expected.
JACOB ANDREAS: The
thing that surprised me
most was the number
of students who
said, I've never done
an assignment like this
in my whole undergraduate
or graduate training, right?
And this is an advanced class.
These are people who
are seniors in college
or in their first or second
year of graduate school.
And for many people,
it was really
the first time they'd actually
been asked to sort of think
about the process by which
these data sets that they've
been seeing since, you
know, their sophomore year
were actually being generated.
HARINI SURESH: Initially,
we had designed
this to focus on subjectivity
that annotators might have--
so like subjectivity
in labels in data sets.
But there were a
bunch of other things
that people learned about
the entire data set pipeline.
So for example,
the categorizations
that people came up with
for the same problem
were drastically
different in some cases.
People were sort of surprised
by how much personal judgment
they had to use to
decide these things.
Everyone was like,
wow, I was very
surprised by the amount
that I wasn't sure
and the amount that I had to
sort of rely on my own biases
or judgments to decide what I
actually thought about this.
SARAH HANSEN: And these
students' reflections actually
pointed to much bigger questions
within the field as a whole.
JACOB ANDREAS: Of the numerous
ways that Harini and Catherine
mentioned of constructing
these data sets,
one that has become
I think particularly
important within the machine
learning research community
these days is
crowdsourcing, where
there's some online portal where
people can log in and sign up
for a teeny little
labeling task-- like just
look at this one picture
and tell me whether or not
this is a picture of a cat.
Or look at this one
comment and tell me
whether it's a toxic
comment or not.
And then you get $0.05 or $0.10
in exchange for doing this
little micro task.
So there's two sorts of
things to think about when
using these kinds of platforms.
One is just thinking
about the well-being
of the annotators
themselves, that it's
very easy to miss calibrate
the amount of time
that it takes to do one
of these micro tasks
and wind up not
actually paying people
a living wage for doing them.
And there are actually
people all over the world who
rely on these kinds of
crowdsourcing platforms
as their primary
source of income.
And another thing--
once you, again,
start to think about tasks like
toxic comment detection or even
more sensitive things
like recognizing images
of pornography or images
of violence or whatever,
it is relatively easy-- without
you as the sort of system
builder yourself having had
to look at any of this data--
to dump just an enormous amount
of like really traumatizing
content on people who you're
paying $0.10 a pop to label.
And there's all kinds of studies
showing that people really
experience post-traumatic stress
disorder, various other kinds
of mental health
issues when subjected
to these kinds of things.
SARAH HANSEN: In
our conversation,
this notion of context
kept coming up.
The context in which data
are created, pulled from,
and annotated is
incredibly important
when thinking about how to
improve machine learning
systems.
HARINI SURESH: One
thing that comes to mind
is Desmond Patton's
lab at Columbia.
He works on context
aware annotations
of social media data.
So specifically, the work of his
that I read is around Twitter--
so looking at tweets
and specifically
tweets in inner city Chicago.
And the task that
they're trying to do
is analyze tweets from
gang-involved youth in Chicago.
And if you look at
some of these tweets,
they're trying to
annotate them with things
like whether they're
violent or whether they
indicate that there's a
violent event going on.
And if you were
to just read them
without any awareness
of the context
and try to annotate
them, something
that seems like it's super
violent, if you actually
were in the context and
were part of that community,
you might know that it's like
a lyric from a local rapper
or something that requires
a lot of community
specific expertise.
So what they did in this
project was actually
get experts from the community
to look through this data
and do context aware annotation.
And they found that
they were able to do
a much better analysis
of this data that
was much more accurate and
grounded in the actual context
that it was a part of.
So that's, I think,
one example where,
if you were to just
apply generic tools,
you would really
fail at this task.
CATHERINE D'IGNAZIO: There
are problems pieces that are
slightly less
culturally fraught,
where there's less room
for stereotypes, bias,
pre-existing structural
inequalities to enter
into, like if we're training
a system to recognize numbers
in an image--
you know what I mean?
That is just--
there's less room.
I mean, obviously there's
still going to always
be space for interpretation,
but there's less room
because we don't have
pre-existing conceptions
of number 9's unworthiness or
something like this, right?
But it's more when we enter into
data about using human language
or that is being used for
decision-making systems that
have real-life consequences
for human beings.
So if we're training resume
screeners, for example--
so like systems
where a large company
would do an automated
system to screen
resumes and then only
put the top ones up
to the humans or whatever.
We're baking in a lot of
biases in the process,
and that has to do with where
the data are coming from.
And it also has to do with
who are labeling the data
and then who are developing
the technologies.
And it's not because
they're evil, you know.
Like, it's not because
there's bad people
at all stages of this pipeline.
It's that we haven't
sufficiently kind of trained
people along the way.
There are tools to deal
with bias, stereotypes,
structural inequalities.
But they just-- they come
from other disciplines.
So how do we bring
those things together
to ultimately develop a more
robust system that works better
for everybody?
But just because the data are
not the subject of ground truth
doesn't mean we just
throw up our hands
or, like, forget about it,
we can never do anything.
It just means we have to enter
with more caution and more
transparency and reflexivity
around what are the boundaries
and the applications of the
knowledge that we're producing.
SARAH HANSEN: I asked
Jacob, Harini, and Catherine
what they'd like to hear
from you, our listeners,
about how to help students
take a critical approach
to computing.
HARINI SURESH: One
question that I
have that I've
been thinking about
is, what's the right format
to introduce students
to these concerns?
So in this case, we
did an assignment
within a machine learning class.
And I wonder, how
does that compare
to sort of having it be a small
portion of every assignment
instead of just one assignment?
Or how does that
compare to having
a class that's more
primarily dedicated
to social and ethical concerns?
CATHERINE D'IGNAZIO:
This is my eternal thing
with these classes
there's like how
do you weave in the critical
while still giving people--
empowering people with tools
to ultimately change practices
and also to change the
tools eventually too.
Because the tools don't in
themselves also work perfectly.
They all have
their own politics.
So if people have
ideas about how
do you both build skills
but also have them
interrogating tools,
interrogating politics,
the critical context in
which the tools are used,
I would love feedback
or ideas around that.
SARAH HANSEN: If
you have insights
to share about engaging
students in thinking
about the social and ethical
responsibilities in computing,
please get in touch with us
at the link in our show notes.
And when you do, you'll be
joining Catherine, Harini,
and Jacob in spotlighting just
how human the digital world is.
If you're interested in learning
from their open and free
teaching materials or remixing
them in your own teaching,
you can find them on our
MIT OpenCourseWare website.
Thank you so much for listening.
Until next time, signing off
from Cambridge, Massachusetts,
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
Chalk Radio's producers
include myself, Brett Paci,
and Dave Lishansky,
scriptwriting assistance
from Aubrey Calaway.
Show notes for this episode
were written by Peter Chipman.
The SERC resource site on OCW
was built by Cathleen Nalezyty.
We're funded by MIT Open
Learning and supporters
like you.